Speaker 1: So after covering a couple of
notable anti-vaccine COVID deaths last week,
many of you over the weekend sent me all sorts
of other examples of this and there's a couple
I want to highlight and I highlight these not to
point the finger and laugh at people. I don't find
that there's anything to laugh at, but to show
all of the different ways in which this toxic,
delusional thinking infects people. And then they
end up in horrible situations. Their families end
up in horrible situations, and it's absolutely
horrifying. An anti-vaccine podcaster who got
COVID at a conspiracy con conference during which
COVID conspiracies were spread has now died of
COVID. I'm talking about sixty one year old Doug
Kuzma, a Q and on an anti-vax podcaster, has died
from complications due to COVID after getting
the virus at a conspiracy theory conference,
which became a superspreader event where attendees
blamed their illness on an anthrax attack.
I don't know if you remember that. Last week, or
maybe it was the week before I told you about this
conspiracy conference where tons of people got
COVID and they said we believe we were targeted
with anthrax and of course you apply a simple,
kind of colloquial Occam's razor. What's more
likely that anthrax, which is difficult to get in
the U.S., really more prevalent in other parts of
the world and is what's responsible as a targeted
attack against us when the symptoms are the one of
the virus that's rapidly spreading everywhere?
Why would we choose the anthrax over the code?
Well, didn't make any sense. This guy has now
died, not from anthrax, but from COVID. Doug
Kuzma, a 61 year old from Newport News, Virginia,
died after being hospitalized 10 days earlier.
Kuzma broadcasted on the Frog News Podcasting
Network, which stands for Fully Rely on God.
Kuzma and his fellow hosts pushed an array of
conspiracy theories ranging from Q and On to COVID
denial and election fraud lies. Kuzma attended
the Reawakened America conference in Dallas on
the weekend of December 11th, posting a picture
of his Media Pass. Other images posted show
large crowds in confined spaces with no social
distancing or masks. I literally told you guys
when we would look at clips from Reawaken America,
these are COVID health shapes and now he has died.
The conspiracy laden event organized by Tulsa
businessman Clay Clark, was headlined by people
like the disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn. Conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones and Eric Trump, several unvaccinated
conspiracy theorists and fraud promoters
basically claimed they were targeted with anthrax.
Kuzma reported he was feeling ill, claimed it was
chronic bronchitis flaring up again. From the
picture, he looks obese and chronic bronchitis.
And you don't get a vaccine. And when COVID is
rampantly spreading, you go to a conference with
tons of other unvaccinated and unmasked people.
It's really unbelievable. Some on December 15th,
he posted that he had a fever. Someone commented
that he should get a COVID test and he said No
way. He was told better safe than sorry, and he
lashed out, saying you must have lost your mind
so they can kill me and try to give me the jab.
I'll die at the house before I go to the hospital.
Well, after suffering for fever for five days,
he was forced to admit he probably had COVID.
He was found unconscious at his house on
Christmas Eve and rushed to the hospital.
He was not responding to treatment. He
was sedated and placed on a ventilator.
According to a fellow member, the final
message Kuzma sent was a photo of himself.
With a refill of ivermectin, oh my God. His
daughter stopped sharing posts about his condition
because she was against his truther movement.
He pushed anti-vax conspiracies. They also
promote promote multilevel marketing company Life
Wave on the Frogged network, which sells wearable
patches that promise to activate your stem cells
and reset them to a younger, healthier state.
Man, you know, this is instructive in so
many ways. The MLM stuff he was pushing,
it didn't help him survive, the ivermectin
didn't help him. He didn't get the vaccine. And,
you know, Candace Owens recently said
she'll die before getting the vaccine.
That is clearly that there are people choosing
that there are people choosing that and this is
sad. This is not something I look at and I laugh
at, and we have another example to look at the